翻訳: sato imo98
校正: Kumika Moore
こんにちは 小林 章です
ドイツから来ました
ドイツで欧文書体のデザインをしています
欧文書体 つまり
アルファベット ABCですね
それを作っています
今こちらに映っているフォントは
これは私の作ったものではないです
ちょっとふざけてみました
これを見た時に
「このTEDっていうイベントと
これ内容合ってんのか？」っていうふうに
思った人いません？
たぶん たいていの人は
思ったと思うんですけども
ちょっとふざけて作ったわけで
実際のTEDのロゴは
ここにも 後ろにもあるように
真ん中のものですよね？
いろんなフォントがある中から この
あえてこのオーソドックスな形を
フォントを選んでロゴにしています
で このロゴを選んだ理由
というのは やっぱり
例えばロゴで伝えたい何かが
あるわけですよね
それは例えば
「落ち着いて聴ける話ですよ」とか
「怖い話じゃありませんよ」とか
それから まあ「信頼できる内容ですよ」
そんなことをこのロゴで
表現したいわけです
まあ 安心感を言葉の形で
表現するわけですよね？
まあ 変なもので場違いなものは
おかしいってすぐ気づいちゃうんですよ
でも 当たり前の使い方をされると
当たり前すぎて そこに
注意がいかないんですよね
例えば たまたまTEDには
向いてないかもしれないですけども
いろんなフォントがあります
例えば「子供受けする」とか
「中世ヨーロッパの話ですよ」とか
あるいは「かわいい」
「高級感があってオシャレ」とか
そんな演出に向くフォントって
たくさんあります
目的に合っていれば
使いたくなりますよね？
まあ今のスライドを作っているところは
これですけれども
こんなふうに
フォントを選ぶメニューがあって
グラフィックアプリケーションの中にね
何百というデザインがあって
その中から選びます
フォントのデザインという仕事について
知っている人は少ないかもしれません
でも それを作った人がいるはずで
で 新しいフォント 面白いフォント
場面場面で使い分けたくなりますよね？
で その「じゃあ新しいフォントを
作りましょう」となった時に
デザイナーのやること フォントを作る
デザイナーのやることって何か？
まず 大変なことがあります
２つの矛盾した事を
同時に実現しなくちゃいけないんですよ
例えば 文字が「A」なら
「A」に読めることって大事です
自分でアルファベットの形を
発明するわけじゃなくて
それを他の人が読めなかったら
使い物にならないですよね？
で フォントデザイナーの作る「A」は
だから どこかで見たことのある
形でなくちゃいけません
でも一方で「新しい」と
誰もが認めるような形でなくちゃいけない
その矛盾と戦っているわけです
これは1990年代に私が作って
世界的な欧文フォントのグランプリを
受賞したフォントです
これと この次に別のフォントで
別のグランプリを受賞しました
カテゴリーがいくつかあって
私は一番ハードルが高いと思った
本文用書体のカテゴリーで応募しました
本文フォントですから
そんなに奇抜な形はできないですよね？
で どこかで読んだことのある
どこかで見たことのある形で
まあ 基本的な本格的な書籍が組める
でも グランプリを受賞したということは
これが新しい 今までにない
と認めてもらったということになります
実際にフォントは
いろんなところで使われていて
たまたま通りかかって
見つけた例ですけども
このパンフレットはベルギーで
学校の講演に行った時に見つけました
はい このアメリカの例は
ベテランのデザイナーが
私のフォントを使ってくれて
気に入ったというので
ブックデザイナーがね
私のフォントを使った例と一緒に
感謝の手紙とともに送られてきました
で これは私のもう１つ
２回目のグランプリを獲った時のフォントです
これオランダですね
まあ これがきっかけになって
2001年にドイツの会社に招かれ
それ以来ずっと欧文フォントのデザインの
ディレクションをしています
さて 私は日本人で
しかも まあ生まれつきの
バイリンガルでもなんでもないのに
29歳になるまで
日本の外に一歩も出たことがないのに
読みやすい欧文フォントを作っています
まあ 小さい時から文字全般に
興味があったんですね
文字のデザインの仕事を始めて
最初は日本の漢字のデザインをしてました
で それで左側にある
ヘルマン・ツァップさんの本と出会って
それを読んだ後で
「ああ これはツァップさんと同じように
ペンを持って勉強すれば
欧文フォントがわかるかもしれない」
そう思ってロンドンに行きました
で ロンドンの街を歩き回っている時に
小さい本屋で見つけたのが
この写真右の
アドリアン・フルティガーさんの本です
これらの本を読んでいくと
まあ 文字を読むこと 物を見ることが
どういうことか少しわかった気がします
いろんな人から 「日本人に
欧文フォントなんかできるわけないよ」と
言われたんですけども
私はできると思ってました
だって日本人でも
世界的な舞台で活躍してる人って
いっぱい いるじゃないですか
例えばオーケストラの指揮者とか
西洋料理のシェフだっている
そしてドイツの会社では
まあ 日本で憧れていたデザインの巨匠と
一緒に仕事をすることができました
で 実際に彼らからも
たくさん学びましたし
作り終えたフォントを見て
彼らも満足してくれました
で そういう仕事ができるっていうのは
たぶんイギリスで一生懸命いろんなものを
見てきたからじゃないかなと思うんですよね
街を歩き回ったり
石を掘る工芸家のところに
泊まりに行って勉強したり
あるいは美しい活字の本に
出会ったりしました
いっぺんに全部が理解できたとは
思いませんけれども
それを何でもいいから見て
それで日本に帰ってきたのが1990年です
日本の空港に降り立った時に周りを見て
「日本の英文の見え方がなんか
ロンドンと違うな」というふうに感じました
同じ英文を使っているのに
なんで見え方が違うんだろう？
そういうことを考えたわけです
で 読みやすさとか読み方のリズムとか
そういったことって
何だろうっていうことを考えました
まあ ここは大学なので
この「University」という単語で
ちょっと実験してみましょう
割と長めの単語ですよね？
これを１文字ずつ読んでいるかというと
まあ そうでもないですよね？
実際は これはあの単語の形
輪郭を一目で捉えて
それで単語を理解しているわけです
まあ この形が崩れたら読みにくいですよね？
一つひとつの字は読めるのに
単語の塊としてはちょっと読みにくい
もう１つですけど リズム感も大事ですよね？
文字が黒で印刷されるとすると
その黒の文字と文字との間の白い部分
この部分も非常に重要なんですけども
これが台無しになるとやっぱり読みにくい
で元に戻すと まあ
このリズム感 安心できますよね？
このリズム感というのは
例えば 意識しないで歩いている時の
歩幅みたいなもので
なにかこう無理やり何かしようとすると
途端にギクシャクしてしまう
そんなもんじゃないでしょうか？
文字も同じです
駅や空港 それから街の中で
いろんな案内 サインがあります
で まあ
これを作っている人がいるわけですよね？
この文字を作っている人がいる
でも皆さん なかなか
そこまで考えたことがない
実際に 例えば今日この会場に来る時に
いろんな案内を見て
それでここへ
たどり着いているわけですけども
その時のフォントが
どんな形だったかって覚えてますか？
たぶん覚えてないと思うんですよね
それが 覚えてないということは
気にならなかった
問題がなかったということで
問題なく たどり着けた
その問題は フォントデザイナーとか
このサインを作る人たちとかが
あらかじめ取り除いているわけです
で その苦労も
やはり日本の中でこういったものを見ると
よくわかるんですけども
ちょっと残念な使われ方を
していることがあって
この欧文書体のデザイナーという眼から見て
で そのデザイナーもやはり
普通の生活の中に入れば本も読むし
街の中に出ればこういったサインも見ます
そういったところを見ると
やっぱりこう
もうちょっと何とか改善できることが
あるんじゃないかなというふうに思います
近年のヨーロッパでは
心地よさを考えたフォントが
主流になりつつあって
世界の空港や駅などで使われている
「Frutiger」というフォントを
使ったサインが多くなってます
さっき写真に出てもらった
アドリアン・フルティガーさんが作りました
ヨーロッパで全般的に
使われているフォントは
文字の懐 つまり空間部分を
広く取ったデザインですね
日本ではまだしっかり巻き込んだ文字が
主流な感じがします
はい ではちょっと比較してみましょうか
上が「Helvetica」という書体
下が「Frutiger」という書体です
まあ別に はっきり見えている状態だと
どちらも問題なく読める
というふうに思うかもしれません
でも夕方とか悪天候だとか
そういった条件の悪いことを
考えてみてください
ちょっと同じ程度ぼやかして
シミュレーションしてみますね
こんなふうにすると いっぺんに
その読みやすさに差が出てくるのが
わかると思います
まあドイツではこういう実験の結果を受けて
2013年に標識などに使われる
フォントのリストを発表していて
「Frutiger」というフォントが
そこで推奨されています
日本では その巻き込みが強い
幅広のフォントを選んで
しかも 掲示板に収まらないからといって
文章全体を左右から縮める
傾向がありますけども
読みやすくはないですよね？
文字と文字との空きはまるで無駄なスペースと
思われているような感じがします
これも文字と同じくらい大切なんです
ただ 左右の幅に限りがあるっていうことも
十分理解できます
そういうところのために
コンデンス体と呼ばれるフォント
まあ 種類があるわけですけれども
ただ左右を縮めたわけではなくて
フォントのデザイナーがあらかじめ
縮めたときの見え方がどうなるかを
調整しているわけですね
どういう調整をしてるかというと
まあ これは縦棒も横棒も
同じ太さで作った「H」です
横棒の方が太く見えませんか？
で あとは横棒がちょっと
下がって見えませんか？
これは目の錯覚によるものですよね
で フォントにする時には
その目の錯覚を取り除いておきます
あるいは この正円を左右から潰すと
綺麗な楕円になるでしょうか？
ならないんですよね
自然に落ちついた形の方が
目に心地よいはずです
そういった目に心地よい
補正のされたコンデンス体が
例えばアメリカでは
こんなふうに使っているし
ドイツ あの 道路の名前とか
結構長いんですけれども
あらかじめ こう左右に縮めた
コンデンス体を使っているわけです
幅広のフォントを選んでから
左右を縮小するのでなく
ちゃんとそういったフォントを
選んでいるわけですね
一方 この東京の例はどうでしょうか？
これちょっと読みやすいでしょうか？
これは東京の渋谷のバス停ですけれども
こんなふうに組まれています
これを「Frutiger」で
先ほどスイスの高速道路の例で見た
「Frutiger」に置き換えてみると
書体をちょっと変えるだけで
いい書体を—
適材適所という言葉がありますけども
そういった書体を選ぶだけで
こんなふうに見え方が美しくなるし
読みやすくなりますね
さて これだけでももう十分
読みやすくなっているんですけど
もう１つ これをもっと読みやすくする
ヒントがあるんですね
今これを全部大文字だけで
組んでますけれども
これを大文字と小文字で組んだら
その方がもっと読みやすいですよね？
まあ 単語の形がはっきりわかるので
一瞬で理解しやすい
で いろんな形のフォントがあります
これはスイスの例ですけれども
時には まるで声のように
言葉の表情を与えてくれますね
で
一方その 必要な時には目立つけれども
必要でない時には そんなに目立たない
そういったフォントを
作る人たちがいるということも
ここで覚えておいていただきたいと思います
普段何気なく通り過ぎている
標識ですけれども
こんなふうに いろんな工夫が
隠されているということを
ここで覚えて帰っていただきたいと思います
どうもありがとうございます
（拍手）
（歓声）